c'è chi e musica david guetta è da tutti
ragazzi e prevenuti è che cazzo bella
tutti ragazzi e bramini tosi in questo
nuovo video io sono fa vigente oggi
stiamo in un nuovo episodio di rocket
league mi chiami ricordavo il nome spero
che la mia condizione sia un pochettino
migliorata ma leggermente per fare i
culi allora proviamo a fare tipo faceva
la partita 4 contro 4 sia caso sono
contro fa direi che ha un nome si è
generata mente simile al mio solo io
sono fa vicenza o tutti semi
professionisti ma [ __ ] mavava era
per dargli un po di vantaggio perché
all'inizio 6 c'è quella tensione ancora
non capito ragazzi perché lui ha la
corona
beh bella che mira io io invece non ce
l'ha la corona che è stata avara [ __ ]
che cazzo farci traiano andare in porta
vai vai ti fai qualcosa compagno del
cazzo perché segna ora che segnò e lo
solcano hanno assegnato mio compagno
bravo zio sarmi ha qualcosa ragazzi ci
siamo è l'uno a zero era tattico melo
detto che la per vincere effetto mai
visto che madonna che gol e gol che gol
abbiamo fa in due
cioè io spinto lui contro non ho capito
un cazzo non lamachi colera
cioè io ho spinto lui contro la pa la
nuova delega e siamo contro due
professionisti di sta minkia è un vorrei
dire ai fratta e qualche gol era va
questa è la mia porta a fa vj assegnata
una schiacciata che cazzo successo non
vuole adesso segno di nuovo ecco ma
[ __ ] devo segnare perché devo far
vincere la mia [ __ ] squadra come ti
permetti e tua madre di vivere
14 secondi guardali come te l'ho toccata
ebbene sì chi è vero fa vj facciamone
una doppia classificata ragazzi che ci
serve contro il pro della madonna di
rocket league ma tanta la vinciamo
perché noi siamo più pronti non si è
cagato addosso che stava lenta però mi
piace di più prima guarda che ti deve
morì la famiglia non lo sto morendo
scusa zio e dei gol
non ci credo ho spiegato d'aver dove
dove dove dove dovrei dove sta lista
lista li mamma ho visto proprio il
vostro culo che si restringeva ragazzo
sì no no no parate fate qualcosa nella
vita bravo vegeta bravo vegeta parata di
vegeta tiro ma dai [ __ ] gigi vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai ed è gol ed è
fottutamente gol
[Musica]
harry henry cavill tu sei un mago harry
questo ragazzo è il primo abbastanza
forte che vedo ma non ci sarà storia
comunque lo zio ovvero zio che
trucchetti che trucchetti ma doloroso
saltato giusto segno così se segno così
madonna che cosa è il gol assurdo uno me
lo sono saltato e poi di nuovo madonna
ma toccherò ma questa è questa è stata
l'azione del secolo riga il culetto con
le vette sinistra non sopra no no no no
no no no no no 2 a 3 per lui siamo così
alla fine ragazzi strutture a mille
sudore cominciare rimane lì io non c'è
mai verso guarda che [ __ ] ho
finalmente buttarsi si tra 33 nicastro
sudando sul serio forza ragazzi dai
enorme lo sento che queste buone
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
dai
sì bravo zio è sbagliato porta è
sbagliato morto era l'altra anzi con
altri 4 a 3 per farli j ancora il 47
secondi dalla fine
ora che non stava preparando cazzo cioè
non so come ha fatto entrare come glielo
tolta madonna cosa ho tolto lo so
neanch'io ho vinto ho vinto vinto vinto
sto sudando dell'acqua frizzante la
corda ragazzi facciamo l'ultima
classificata che per ora le ho fatte
comunque sono classificate dove c'è la
gente coi contro maroni ci siamo ragazzi
siamo io contro gente tanta brutta uno
che si chiama pupa che sotto sotto melo
zuppa buttiamo avanti perfetto faccio io
vada che aspettiamo domani mattino che
[ __ ] sta macchina mi piace un sacco
guardavo li guardo lì no
tanta roba regala tanta [ __ ] rho e
cosa hanno
ciao andiamo con i j faccio il dj bravo
butta in mezzo qualcuno segni fatto un
assist e la madonna bravo ragazzo
bravissimo gol di falli j.lo almeno con
i ragazzi col mio scappare la palla come
glielo tolta come imparata epica solo
epica zio parata fa vigenti forse sì
invece ma che cazzo lo sapevo che
abbiamo perso 3 1
ci abbiamo provato ragazza siccome non
posso accettare gli aver perso l'ultima
ne faccia un'altra metto solo alle parti
più belle ed è rete studiate di chiasso
e segno così
oddio madonna se segniamo così ragazzi
cioè stavo prendendo un infarto
rovesciata a caso proprio è niente
ragazzi beh ragazzi ci siamo e di dove
va beh io non ho ormai ormai ormai non
c'è non c'è storia nella vita proprio
giacosa guarda che break dance non
riparte fuori gente di parte fa vj
riparte e barry j
ciao farci gol
tu no tu non li fa e finisce qui ragazzi
sono 6 a 3
non so perché quando finisce doversi
scatti dei ragazzi è stato bello si è
fatto anche buio nel mentre che iniziato
a giocare in 12 ore di gioco i ragazzi
spero che ho visto mi sia piaciuto
chiama sento se mi è piaciuta certo
punto mi piace un mi piace per buffa
perché anche voi in fondo sapete che lo
zucca
quindi ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma se
avete lasciato come christie anni è
caduto il caso se vi è piaciuto lasciato
come tu mi piace anche la pace di
facebook come lo trovate la descrizione
sensi discrete ci vediamo il prossimo
video della ruga che cazzo succede è
partita a partita
che cazzo se ne frega bella ragazza